>>> MONE
GAN, AN EXTREMELLAR
OUNCEDAL
MEDIA DA
PEOPLE DON'T NEED TO GET
IN HIS STEROGAN SAID HS TAL
THERAPEUTI TCOVER.
>> TURNSUT GOTE IMMEDIATELTHE
HEN SINK O, S
AIB
IVERG ZONE
EVERYTHING.
>> ONE OF THOSE DRUGS HED, IVE
FTEN USETO  HS.AS USAGEUB I
OVERDOSES AFTER A PUM THFAR RIGS
WHO HAS PODC, Y G
PEOPLE PROBABLY DON'T NEED TO
GEIOAT HE'S SAYI HIS
CONDITION?
>> YEAH, AND HE IS O
MOST INFLUENTIAL FIGURES IN ALL
$0 MILLION.EAL AMONG YOG
BUT IN THE PAST HE'S DOWN-PLAYED
BECAUSE IT'S HURTING HIM IN  VE
HE HAD TO POSTPONE OR RESCHEDULE
ONE OFG STAGE SHOW.
YOU'D TE
EC GET
AT
'STHIS AS IF HE'S
DOING BETT BESE COCKTAIL OF DRU
MEDICATIONS HE'S TAKENCH OF
COURSE SOME OF ARE UNDY USIZATI.
KNOW, HAVE BEESCOURAGE BY THE C.
BUT WHEN YOU HAVE MEDICATION ZUE
VERNMENTHAISE'TOLY WANT TO TRY
THE UPSIDE DOWN WE'RIN IVERMECTO
AND STUFF, BUT WHAT IS THE
THEORY THA
>> WELL,
BELIEVE THAT
THER AICR
RSE WE WOULD ALLS THE MAIN
WITHLY IS TH-- NOT ONLY ARE WE
WORKS. THERE'S NO EVEN
ITS BEYOND
WE'RE ACTUALLY SAYING IT
WORK.
THERE WAS A SYSTEMAT REVIE
BEG DO AT DIFFEREN
SE IVER MECKTEN, ANDY
FOUND THERE UC
IT DOET WORK.COVID9.
WHEN EVEIN
S NO BENEFIT, THEN
NOT SOMETHING THAT SHOULD BEAND
HET PROVIDES US
PEOPLEREOW NOT
GETTING CCYIDO
E UNDERSTANDING THATRE
A SATHE EN T
NOT C PILL THA EN
SIDE TAKINIT?
RYN HAS FFECTS ANDN ESPECIALLY
INLL
IVERCTN HOORPARASITES ANSCABIESO
, DIARRHEA, SEVERE SKIN
RALO
DAMAGE.E ANDNT
YOU COULD ALSO DIE